this community pride special on eight
news now
is sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state
after a tough year las vegas is now open
for business
but are we back to normal when will
conventions and international travelers
return
why have some employees chosen not to
return to work how are casinos keeping
visitors safe
vegas now open an eight news now
community pride special
this eight news now community pride
special is sponsored by our community
pride partners
findlay automotive group southwest
medical part of optim care
and silver state schools credit union
the lights are on performers are on the
stage and the people
are back vegas is open thanks for
joining us for this community pride
special i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis over the next half hour we're
going to look at some of the challenges
and successes our city has faced
we're going to start with a brand new
opening happening in just a couple of
days
talking about resorts world which is
going to be opening very soon
resorts world might be the new kid on
the block but it's certainly not the
only game in town
orca mana explains opening brand new
resorts in the midst of a pandemic is
definitely a gamble
even in the gambling mecca of the world
circa virgin and
resorts world are all part of a new era
for las vegas
but experts say a full economic recovery
is still
several months away
[Music]
the entertainment capital of the world
is expanding las vegas welcoming new
resorts even amid
covet 19.
hotels las vegas formerly the hard rock
opened in late march
so how's business it's as expected
richard boz bosworth president of the
property's ownership group tells me
operations are not quite at pre-pandemic
levels
but the future looks promising our hotel
reservations interesting enough now
as we work through the softness and as
we see a light at the end of the tunnel
with kovid
are now starting to pick up
significantly for the second half of the
year downtown it's hard to miss circa
the first resort to open during the
pandemic back in october
it's great to see the demand owner
derrick stevens says reservations are
ramping up
now that there are little to no coveted
restrictions i've never seen
eight weeks of booking trends like what
we're seeing here what he looked like
going out to june july
august through the rest of the year it's
really been outstanding
up next is resorts world slated to open
june 24th it'll be the first new resort
completed on the las vegas strip
in more than a decade we're like in the
ninth inning of a baseball game
and we're almost there president scott
sabella hopes it state of the art
technology and list of impressive
residencies will bring a business boom
to the north end of the strip
we're excited and again it won't happen
overnight but business will shift this
way
in the future i think this will be the
luxury side of the strip the new resorts
are finding their footing just as las
vegas comes back
online the city went to full capacity on
june 1st
but when will our economy actually see
the results of this rebound
we still have some work to do to get
back to something we would say is a
pre-code 19-month analyst jeremy aguero
tells me that'll take about one year
because more business and international
travelers still need to come to the
strip but he expects things to pick up
soon
we know those business travelers spend
more we know international travelers
stay longer
and spend more than their domestic
counterparts there's no doubt that this
window
i think which is really going to be
between june and september that las
vegas
is incredibly well positioned to take it
to take advantage of a run-up
in consumer activity as far as what
visitors want at the new resorts
a full pool and a nice bar a different
experience makes people want to come
back so that's what i'm looking for
the new property is promising to meet
those expectations and thrilled to be
doing it together
with us and circa and resorts world and
to be able to
renew that statue within the
entertainment industry for the community
worldwide i look forward to that as well
and it's safe to say we're all rooting
for these new resorts to succeed
as las vegas gets back on track orca
mana 8 news now
in addition to the millions of visitors
who come to las vegas each and every
year
trade shows really vital to our area
economy yeah conventions bring in
millions of visitors but they create
billions of dollars every year david
charns explains how
conventions are the heartbeat of this
city the
recognition that meetings and
conventions will now be back
is pretty exciting for all of us and
really important for the city you could
say important is an understatement when
it comes to conventions
in las vegas it's an industry bringing
an estimated
11 billion dollars to the local economy
a business
that amid the pandemic added 3 million
square feet of space
to house a growing demand we're excited
about
what the next 12 months will break but
above the convention center's new
underground loop
and outside the glimmering walls of the
new west hall
businesses and hotels relying on all
this see a flood of potential
the conventions usually come at a time
that you need them
and we needed them more than ever last
year and
this year it's nice to see them coming
back john simmons owns firefly near
paradise and twain
it's just like rain you know i mean it
falls on everybody it
feeds everybody so all the people that
work in all these businesses like our
restaurants and on the strip and
everything else that depend on these
tourists and these conventions
they they get fed and then they spend
the money in the local economy and it
just helps everybody
2019 set records for the las vegas
convention industry
a record 6.6 million people attended a
convention here
filling some 130 000 hotel rooms during
the week
and fueling 50 000 jobs this is where we
get our product out people get to try it
but in addition to the benefits these
large-scale meetings play
to tourism and restaurants it's that
one-on-one experience
exhibitors come to display i want to get
to know people i want to know why you
struggle why you succeed and what i can
do about it
now after a year off not only is this a
great day for las vegas it's really a
great day for the entire country the
entire industry
conventions and a booming sector for las
vegas
are back i'm david charns 8 news now
the first convention to return is world
of concrete coming up next
is the amusement expo followed by the
nightclub and bar
show the largest of them all though is
still ahead that's ces
coming in january not too long ago the
president and ceo of the las vegas
chamber of commerce
talked to our good day las vegas team
mary beth seawall talked about some of
the challenges that businesses faced
returning and reopening we have to
really make sure that we
are prepared and in some cases you'll
see
longer lines and things like that so so
there are challenges with the increased
demand
but i think overall um employers across
the state
and especially in southern nevada are
doing an excellent job of
being being very creative about how
we're handling that increased demand
seawalled went on to say over recent
weekends hotels have been at capacity
and businesses have seen the uptick in
customers and sales
she says the prevailing attitude is one
of optimism
one group really hit hard during the
pandemic small business owners and while
some closed
others survived and are bouncing back
here's 8 news now reporter joe moller
[Music]
it was definitely scary when we first
shut down you're being told not to go up
you are being told not to go up las
vegas was turned upside down when the
governor's orders to shut down
became a reality it's been very
challenging
we're working our way through it none
essential businesses restaurants and
bars were all forced to close
as companies got the green light to
reopen granny hit the ground running
we're looking forward for it to come to
an end
medy zarlul is the owner of crazy peta
there are three valley locations
the way of operating has changed and we
have to change with it and accommodate
to it accordingly
he says after shutting down all
locations business has really picked up
and is showing a positive sign moving
forward
business has a return in some of my
areas as a company
it's it's coming back at the capacity of
9200
restaurants and bars struggled with
capacity changes returning to 100
came with staffing and product struggles
but zarlul says they are working through
it
we've definitely seen that increase in
hours and increasing business
[Music]
sarah wildfong is the manager at
performance footwear in las vegas
she says since reopening business is up
way up
as analytics and statistics came in we
found
that running just boomed running and
walking outside because gyms closed
she said they did not expect the boost
in business but are welcoming it
navigating new hours due to staffing
problems is still a reality but with
more people finding a new hobby and
walking and running
she thinks the future is bright we're
definitely excited to see what summer is
going to bring
historically it's pretty slow during the
summer but we haven't seen any downturn
in sales
both wildfong and zarlul say there is a
light at the end of the tunnel i always
say
time fixes everything reporting in las
[Music]
vegas
and remember there are plenty of job
openings from small businesses to big
companies you can always find a listing
of it
on eightnewsnow.com coming up in our
vegas now open the casino lights are
back on again house station casinos is
preparing to celebrate the big
re-opening
and as more people feel confident to go
see their family and friends
airport officials expecting a busier
than normal travel year
but what about the paws on international
travel
that's ahead stay with us
[Music]
what do we do at fast fit body sculpting
we turn people like this
into people like this we turn people
like this into people like this
and then people like this into people
like this lose inches
findlay automotive group has been
building and investing in southern
nevada for over 60 years
even during the most challenging times
of the pandemic findlay automotive made
a commitment to retain all of our
employees
and to continue construction of new
dealerships in fact findlay continued
hiring throughout the pandemic
and now we have more employees to serve
you than ever before
we're also proud to announce the
completion of our 18th local dealership
philly's jaguar land rover henderson in
the valley auto mall
we believe in this city and we'll never
stop betting on las vegas
medicare advantage members it's time to
put your health first
whether you're with southwest medical or
a contracted network provider
we're here to help you get your annual
wellness screening part of your covered
benefit
we have more than 3 000 providers across
the valley
plus optim care offers at home wellness
greetings
and 24 7 video visits because our care
is always focused on you take advantage
of your benefits
schedule your annual wellness screening
by calling today
here at silver state schools credit
union we do things differently than
other financial institutions
we are a not-for-profit member-owned
credit union
which means you the member benefit from
better rates
and excellent member service
and we make it easy for anyone to become
a member
so what are you waiting for become a
member today and have a financial
partner for life
what do we do at faceted body sculpting
we turn people like this
into people like this we turn people
like this into people like this
and then people like this into people
like this lose inches fast
guaranteed call 1-800
[Music]
many claim it's the final step towards
normalcy
international travel has been on pause
by the federal government
christian casadas explains how one
country though was able to jump the
hurdle
once we got into the air it was so
amazing
watching everything how small everything
was from up there
this philadelphia couple can't stop
smiling after experiencing their first
flight
even though it was domestic they plan to
expand their travel soon we definitely
want to go to japan
you know hawaii but that won't happen
anytime soon for mccarran airport
international flights are still halted
due to pandemic restrictions
we had 11 different countries prior to
the pandemic yeah almost overnight march
of 2020 they all fell out
for the various safety reasons economic
reasons health reasons restrictions that
the government's put in place
international operations are crucial
according to experts
as the final push to get las vegas back
up to full potential
so as this new delta variant starts to
go forward it's a tricky balance you
want to make sure that you're doing
what's
safe and what's in everyone's best
interest in terms of controlling the
pandemic
but on the flip side you've also got
businesses that want to find a way to
open in a smarter fashion
mexico air travel was able to resume
service last summer
because they have fewer restrictions
than other countries and that has been a
crucial lifeline for our local economy
mexico right now is literally the only
market that las vegas has non-stop
service from
or to outside the united states domestic
travel has been very strong according to
airport officials
even the mexico service as more people
come to town to visit family
attend conventions and sporting events
the necessary precautions and everything
i think it should be okay
christian casa is 8 news now airport
officials believe there will be stronger
demand
for fall and winter travel 8 news now
spoke with a station casino's leader
about how they took care of employees
during the pandemic
and the joyous celebration for their
45th year in town
i want to point out a real positive
during the
pandemic and that is what stations did
for their employees talk about the
effort on
on behalf of station casinos and its
leaders to make sure
employees were taken care of during such
a trying time
you know it was such a time of
uncertainty for all of us but one thing
that was never foreshadowed was
our team members are our family and they
were always priority for franklin
roosevelt and for the company itself
so we paid our team members all the way
through the closure and then we even
doubled down to increase their reti uh
add a company paid retirement fund and
then to top it all off anybody making
less than a hundred thousand dollars a
year gets free
uh health benefits and free insurance
for them and their family members
did you hear from from men and women who
worked for you that that was really
life-changing because of what was going
on in the world
and so many people being laid off and so
many people not being paid
we heard from everybody i mean to
provide that kind of comfort in a time
where
everybody doesn't know what's going on i
mean that speaks volumes for just the
company itself and how it works
as people are starting to return you
mentioned it feels like home
what are they gravitating towards i'm
curious is it everything
is it more hey i really want to go out
to a restaurant or bar is it a lot of
the gaming anything specific people
really seem to have missed the most
you know it is a little bit of
everything and the one main thing is the
relationships that we have with all our
guests and we continue to build as we
move forward
a lot of people return for one reason
only and it's our team members
themselves
how do you do that how do you keep that
going with both tourists who like
station properties but also locals who
consider it their casino
we make it a very fun safe and clean
environment everybody comes here with
the priority knowing that they are
number one to us
and we'll always build that relationship
and continue on as great as the strip is
when you come here again you really do
feel like you're at home
we have more ahead tonight on this
community pride special still ahead back
in the spotlight
the las vegas philharmonic prepares to
take the stage once again
after more than a year of silence we'll
check in with how the musicians are
tuning up
coming up we talk with boyd gaming about
the booming return of business
at their multiple properties just ahead
findlay automotive is celebrating 60
years since we opened our first location
here in las vegas
we now have 17 dealerships across the
valley the key to our growth has been
putting people first
not only our customers but our community
too each findlay dealership contributes
time and resources to causes that
they're passionate about
causes like education feeding the hungry
fighting disease
supporting veterans and many more we're
proud to be part of this community and
we look forward to serving southern
nevada
for years to come medicare advantage
members
it's time to put your health first
whether you're with southwest medical or
a contracted network provider
we're here to help you get your annual
wellness screening part of your covered
benefit
we have more than 3 000 providers across
the valley
plus optim care offers at-home wellness
screenings and
24 7 video visits because our care is
always focused on you
take advantage of your benefits schedule
your annual wellness screening by
calling today
here at silver state schools credit
union we do things differently than
other financial institutions
we make it easy for anyone to become a
member and when you do
you'll have access to our full suite of
products and services
things like mobile banking which makes
managing your money simple
secure and convenient right in the palm
of your hand
so what are you waiting for become a
member today and have a financial
partner for life
[Music]
hey are you okay no my nose is killing
me
i always have sinus pressure and i can't
breathe you should go see dr krakowski
at science solutions
he cured my sinuses and now i can
breathe life is good
i'm dr quinkowski at sinus solutions we
can help you breathe again
easy pain-free here in our office
don't suffer with sinus pain any longer
call sinus solutions today
and we'll help you breathe again
[Music]
a year-long intermission for the las
vegas philharmonic is finally over
tickets are now on sale for the upcoming
2021-2022 concert series
hector mejia has our story
for over a year time stood still inside
reynolds hall at the smith center
not a single soul playing music or
coming to hear it it's our home
and and to step into our home after
being gone for so long
is is is a very special feeling the
silence caused by the pandemic shutdowns
ends this october
with intense rehearsals conductor donato
cabrera in the las vegas philharmonic
get to delight audiences again in
november
there's this sense of nervousness of oh
gosh will i be able to conduct again i
haven't conducted an over here what will
that be like
and the musicians of this were felt the
same way you know
will i be able to play this hard music
together with six other music violinists
again i know what we know will happen as
well
is within 30 seconds all that will
go away and we'll be so happy to be with
one another
that's what i'm looking forward to the
theme this year is beethoven's
250th birthday we're not able to
celebrate last year
it was 250th anniversary of his birth in
december of
2020 and we we had grand plans
so we're going to have grand plans again
by celebrating his
birthday all season the orchestra will
perform
all nine of his symphonies along with
music by living american composers
always encourage everyone regardless
if it's music or eating vietnamese food
for the first time
give it a shot we welcome our audiences
we don't expect them to wear
a fancy suit we don't expect them to
know
when to clap and when not to clap we
just want them to
uh experience this beautiful hall that
was built for them
so there you go an open invitation
directly from the conductor
was also the music director hector mejia
reporting
8 news now
[Music]
mark your calendar because opening night
is november 20th
tickets went on sale for packages this
week individual tickets will start in
early september
boyd gaming properties around town are
packed and leaders there are so excited
to see locals
out smiling again it's just so fantastic
to see this i mean it has been such a
long and challenging road for all of us
but to see people coming back and having
fun again
after such a challenging year i mean
it's it's so fantastic i don't know if
any of us could imagine we'd be here a
year from now
but here we've made it and um you know i
think what's going on right now
it's been a very long year a lot of pent
up demand people been staying home
they're trying to social distance
they're being safe and now that folks
are getting vaccinated
they can come out safely again there's a
lot of pent-up demand out there there's
a lot of
energy and people want to come out and
have fun again
and you know what there is no place
better for having fun in las vegas and
that this makes it prime time for us
i'm curious with that pent-up demand and
people being
away from their normal life for so long
what are they most drawn to
or is it kind of a collective everything
as you think about all your properties
what are people really gravitating
towards well if you look at what
at the end of the day what do you get at
a casino one of the biggest things you
get at one of our properties
is that social experience you get to be
around people and have fun
with other people and share that
exciting experience together
and that's what people are coming for
they've been at home
and they've been socially distancing
where we've been telling people for so
long
you got to stay home you got to stay
away from other people
you can go back out now if you have the
vaccine you can go back out you can have
fun again
and so that's really what people are
coming back to our properties and that's
what that's what's bringing them out
here and
back to las vegas and so it's just
really exciting to see that to see that
excitement again to see people out here
having fun again and getting back to
what we do best here in las vegas
now that was just a portion of our
interview you can watch it in its
entirety over on eight newsnow dot com
coming up in our vegas now open special
the big
players are back after the world pause
due to the pandemic
the return of sports to las vegas is
official
plus lighting up the sky after a
challenging year
an epic fourth of july to celebrate the
entertainment capital of the world more
on the july
fireworks coming to the strip
medicare advantage members it's time to
put your health first
whether you're with southwest medical or
a contracted network provider
we're here to help you get your annual
wellness screening part of your covered
benefit
we have more than three thousand
providers across the valley
plus optim care offers at home wellness
screenings
and 24 7 video visits because our care
is always focused on you take advantage
of your benefits
schedule your annual wellness screening
by calling today
findlay automotive group has been
building and investing in southern
nevada for over 60 years
even during the most challenging times
of the pandemic findlay automotive made
a commitment to retain
all of our employees and to continue
construction of new dealerships
in fact findlay continued hiring
throughout the pandemic and now we have
more employees to serve you
than ever before we're also proud to
announce the completion of our 18th
local dealership
philly's jaguar land rover henderson in
the valley auto mall
we believe in this city and we'll never
stop betting on las vegas
here at silver state schools credit
union we prioritize
people over profit
we offer free financial literacy tools
to help you make smart financial
decisions
now and in the future and we invest in
southern nevada by giving back to
schools and to deserving charities
so what are you waiting for become a
member today and have a financial
partner for life
[Music]
aaron taylor here your real estate guy
jacob taylor here your real estate kid
get the highest price for your house
from the number one real estate brand in
nevada
we will give you 10 000 cash advance or
more
within 48 hours for vacation repairs
for bills whatever you want we put our
money where our mouth is
so call the real estate guy today over
25 years of experience and over 6 000
homes sold
[Music]
well we couldn't talk about reopening
without talking about sports
most sports were shut down right in the
middle of march 2020
but they are back in a big way local
sports back with the vegas golden
knights now at 100 percent capacity
and vaccinated attendees do not have to
wear masks
the players will tell you having the
fans back a tremendous advantage
the raiders planning for full crowds for
the first time in allegiant stadium
the raiders say they will use casino
parking to solve any parking problems
we only have 65 thousand fans coming to
the stadium
and then we have about thirty five
hundred four thousand people on staff
so if you had all that up at seventy
thousand you really need one car
for every three point three people so
that's about twenty two
twenty three thousand total we have
thirty five 000. so we do think we have
enough
the las vegas ballpark is also open to
full crowds for the aviators
players aren't yet able to interact with
fans but fans can go to the park
without a mask if they're vaccinated
they've had a few sellouts already at
las vegas ballpark
finally tonight fireworks are officially
coming back to the strip
the lvcva announcing plans for a massive
show on the fourth of july
they'll go off from a number of
properties including aria caesars palace
planet hollywood and the strat
this will be a celebration of not just
independence day but the comeback of our
city with las vegas now fully reopened
that's all for us tonight on 8 news now
thank you for watching
let's celebrate because vegas is now
open good night
[Music]
you